بطريقة ما من المحتمل أن أكون من خلال المدير المالي الخاص بي في
ذلك الوقت فكرة أنه يمكننا القيام
بفكرة ملكية أسهم الموظف التي كنت أحبها
بشكل جيد ويبدو هذا مثيرًا للاهتمام ، دعنا
نستكشف هذا نعم ، لذا عملنا على
ذلك وأعتقد أن 30 بعت 30 بالمائة
إلى  الموظفون والفكرة كانت أنه كان علينا
اقتراض المال من
البنك ثم دفع البنك لي ثم
حصل الموظفون على أسهم ثم حصلنا على
خصم ضريبي كبير ، لذا كان الأمر
مربحًا للجانبين لذا تحدث عن إيمانك
بأن جميع الشركات  يجب أن تفعل هذا اليوم
ونوع الحركة التقدمية
وراء ذلك ، نعم ، ما الذي يجب أن يبدو
عليه ذلك بالنسبة لبعض شركات التجزئة الكبرى الأخرى
التي لديها
مسؤولية ائتمانية تجاه مساهميها ، وأنا
أعلم أنه يتعين عليهم الإجابة كل ثلاثة أشهر على
الأسواق العامة ، وأنا أعلم ذلك ، نعم
أعتقد أنه أمر صعب وأعتقد أنه
يجب عليهم فعل ذلك على أي حال لأنني
أعتقد أنه حتى 10٪ من الأرباح أعتقد
أنها جيدة للروح المعنوية وللأشخاص الذين
يشعرون بأنهم جزء من هذه
الشركة حقًا  يتحدث الأشخاص أكثر عندما
يرون أشياء لا تشعر بأنها على ما يرام أو
يهدر الأشخاص المال هناك
يشعرون حقًا أنها ملكهم أيضًا ، فأنت تعلم
أنهم جزء منها ، لذلك أعتقد أن
هناك فائدة كبيرة من القيام بذلك
يتحدث الموظفون ويقولون إننا لا
نريدك أن تستخدم أموالنا بهذه الطريقة التي
يفعلونها ، نعم ، كمالك ، أعتقد أنك
تعلم ربما لا يجب أن نفعل ذلك
أو تعلم أننا يجب أن نغير هذا أو
تعلم الكثير  من التعليقات
جيدة وهل غيّرت سلوكك
واتخاذك للقرار ، نعم ، أنا أستمع.
أعتقد دائمًا أن هذه هي الطريقة التي أحاول
أن أقود بها ، فأنا أستمع إلى كل من أحب أن
أسمع ما يشعر به الناس
ويفكرون فيه وهذا يؤثر على المكان الذي
نحول فيه  شركة ما نفعله
لك